when do you think we might be getting
another avengers type movie do you think
it's like four years away
five years more we want there to be a
reasonable amount of time
from the end game to to start uh to
start a new saga which is already
underway and already started um and then
you need some time as we did in phase
one to build that saga before you start
uh start um uh bringing everybody
together every day i see on twitter
people wondering when are when is the
spiderman trailer going to drop so i'll
ask you when do you think the spiderman
and the doctor strange two trailers when
do you think they might drop
uh they will both be coming out before
the movie comes out we'll have the
trailer come out first and then before
the movies if you look at the release
date for the movies you go we'll
definitely be before that great got it
okay good
got it um i am curious uh what is the
status of your script the star wars
script with michael uh let me ask that
uh in in the works
improv
is it uh do you envision that can i ask
is that a can you at least say is it a
solo movie or is it one of these things
that could be a movie and a disney plus
thing it is not about han solo han solo
is not in it no well now that it's come
out that anthony is returning for
captain america four do you already have
a release date in mind
yes i mean we always we always uh work
towards release dates it doesn't mean
they don't shift and change certainly as
we've seen uh lately um but uh but we
have we we have something specific in
mind yes do you think it could be
filming next year
uh
i forgot to bring the schedule stephen
sorry